welcome back I'm here with Rossi hi and
uh before the break I held up the
certificate because now it is time
um to welcome its rightful owner yeah
please welcome the world's oldest female
comedian Dion Forest
[Applause]
s
we're so excited to meet you yeah I'm
excited to meet you how does it feel to
be the world's oldest comedian well I
feel old hahaha
how old are you oh man I'm 88 and three
four wow
well you know I uh I got into the
Guinness Book of Records uh I had a
friend of mine who was six months older
than me Lynn Ruth Miller and she was in
it uh but she died last year
what a tragedy but what a lucky break
for me yeah
[Applause]
how did you get into comedy yeah how'd
this start for you well I was playing
piano and singing in lounges for years
in Cabaret I pretended I was French and
the 911 happened and all of a sudden us
musicians were out of work for a year
people were very sad and so I finally
asked a friend of mine
how do you get into comedy and she put
me right in the show after three weeks
people laughed at me I was amazed and so
I've been doing that for 20 years
and so many people have loved you I mean
Joan Rivers right right the one and only
Joan Rivers right she called you the
something the filthy ukulele player is
that true well I used to be in the same
club with her down downtown 21st Street
so they introduced me to her once and I
went downstairs and they introduced the
enforest she says oh yeah the filthy
ukulele player I said oh no Joan I'm
just risque
yeah
I think Dion I might be a little risque
oh really oh dear
yeah well uh now Darren that way you're
about to show us what Joan Rivers meant
are you all ready for a Dr Forest
informed from her comedy routine
take it away Dion
hi everybody yeah
I'm Dion and I'm 88 years old
put it out there right away in case I
don't make it through the show
you know but I I love the young people
oh except after the show a lot of the
young guys come up and they say the same
thing they say Dion you can be my
grandmother
I said but I'm not your grandmother so
if you kiss me I expect a little tongue
foreign
Parts aren't under warranty anymore
but I still have three things that the
younger women don't have
experience a pension and a place in the
Hampton
s
but you know I I talk a lot about sex
you know but I realize that a lot of
people my age
have given up sex not me
my rule is it ain't over till the fat
lady's dead
[Applause]
you can catch Dion perform her one woman
show at The Frigid film festival in New
York City this February thank you Dion
thank you so much
we'll be right back
[Music]